เฮ
[Música]
Olá, pessoal. Boa noite. É um prazer
estar com vocês novamente. Sejam
bem-vindos para mais uma live. Boa
noite, Dr. Ana Paula. Boa noite, Alice
Vogel. A medida que vocês forem
entrando, por favor, dê o seu alô pra
gente poder interagir aqui ao vivo.
Bem, vamos às perguntas da semana.
Primeira pergunta é: Quais são os exames
que eu recomendo para saúde da próstata?
Eu vou fazer essa resposta mais
abrangente porque houve uma pergunta
parecida em seguida. Então eu vou juntar
essas duas perguntas em uma só. Então a
pergunta inicial é: exame de saúde
prostática para homens acima de 50 anos
e demais homens de qualquer idade. Aí
que ficou um pouco
ambíguo essa pergunta, porque homens
muito jovens não precisa fazer exame de
saúde prostática, né? Então é só homens
mais velhos, né? Mas como tem uma
pergunta em seguida, quais exames você
recomenda para saber saúde dos rins
e o exame tem que ser em jejum? Então eu
vou juntar essas duas perguntas numa
resposta para exame de modo geral para
várias idades, tá?
Então, falando primeiro sobre a
próstata, o exame que vocês conhecem
bem, PSA total, você começa a fazer a
partir dos 50 anos de idade, pessoas que
têm risco familiar,
se tiver um parente, por exemplo, um
câncer e prósta, eu recomendo começar
aos 45. Se tiver mais de dois parentes a
começar a fazer a partir dos 40 anos de
idade. Então, na maioria das pessoas, a
partir dos 50, em pessoas com quase na
família, né? Caso uma família de câncer
prostático, pode começar aos 40 ou 45
anos de idade.
Então, a gente considera os valores
normais do PSA até quatro, né? Em
pessoas mais velhas e em pessoas mais
novas, os valores seriam até 2,5.
E a relação PCA total e livre, a gente
usa para pessoas que tm o PCA 4, entre 4
e 10, para tentar decidir quais desses
pacientes vai fazer ressonância de
próstata ou até mesmo biópsia
prostática.
Existem novos marcadores, né, que são
ainda um pouco polêmicos, né, porque são
ainda um pouco caros e também não são
tão perfeitos assim. Você tem, por
exemplo, o exame PHI, que é o prostate
Index, que tem uma especificidade de
90%,
e poderia reduzir biópses necessárias em
até 40%.
Tem também o exame 4K Score, que avalia
quatro isoformas de PSA. Esses dois
exames não têm cobertura por plano, tá?
Então esse 4K score ele prediz
agressividade tumoral e também reduz as
biópses em torno de 20 a 30%. E tem um
exame bem desconfortável que é o PCA,
PCA3 urinário que tem que fazer massagem
prostática. Então por isso ele não se
popularizou. É um outro exame que você
faz de urina após massagem prostática,
que seria melhor que o PSA.
E pessoas que têm PSA elevado
ou uma relação PCA total e livre abaixo
de 20%, você pode pedir uma ressonância
multiparamétrica de próstata que ajuda a
definir melhor quem vai precisar fazer
biópsia prostática e aumenta a detecção
de tumores em torno de 30%.
Agora, outros exames, independentemente
da idade, que foi a pergunta também que
inicial, né? E aí, juntando também com a
pergunta de função renal, aí você faz
exame de urina tipo um, né? Se tiver
alteração na urina tipo um, você
complementa com cultura de urina
antibiograma.
Você pode fazer um perfil hormonal
masculino em homens mais velhos a partir
dos 40 anos de idade, que inclui
testosterona total e livre, SHBG, LHFSH,
para avaliar todo o eixo hormonal,
hipotálamo, hipófigônada.
E pessoas que já estão com mais de 50
anos, é interessante também fazer a
avaliação do DHT, que é de hidrotestosa,
que é um hormônio relacionado à calvice
e aumento prostático. Então, pessoas que
t DHT aumentado tendem a ter calvice,
né, alopsia androgenética masculina e
tende também a ter o HPB e a hipoplasia
prostática benigna. E também eu
recomendo que faça o DHEA sulfatado, que
é um exame que reflete reserva adrenal.
Muitas pessoas que têm fadiga crônica, é
interessante ver esse exame porque se
tiver baixo ajuda a fazer a reposição do
DHA ou prasterona. Em homens é
interessante ver o estradiol, né,
estrona para ver o quanto da
testosterona tá sendo aromatizado ou
sendo transformado nesses hormônios
ditos femininos.
Isso tem a ver também com a obesidade e
pessoas que têm a questão da cina
metabólica, porque quanto mais gordura
corporal, mais você tem a tendência de
converter testosterona em estradiol.
Em relação à avaliação metabólica e
cardiovascular, também homens a partir
dos 40 anos. Eh, mas outros exames são
para todas as idades. Quais seriam esses
exames para todas as idades? A, o
açúcar, né? A glicemia em jejum, a
hemoglobina glicada, a insulina. Isso é
muito importante para ver resistência
insulínica pré-diabetes. Os exames
conhecidos de colesterol total e
frações, né, com as frações HDL, LDL,
VLDL, triglicerídeos. O mais importante
é ver a relação entre triglicerídios
HDL.
Marcadoras inflamatórias como
proteinência reativa ultra sensível que
marca inflamação vascular. Há uma a
homocistena também é outro marcador de
saúde vascular e também risco aumentado
para câncer e trombose.
Fibrinogênio também importante como
marcador inflamatório
para avaliar o estado pró trombótico ou
procoagulante.
Aí você tem também um exame para todas
as unidades, a função tiroidiana, o TSH,
o T3 livre, o T4 livre para rastrear
hipotiroidismo e mais raramente
hipertiroidismo.
E os anticorpos, antitpo
antitiroglobulina para identificar se a
pessoa tem rachimoto tiroidite
autoimune.
Em relação à pergunta sobre função
renal, quais são os exames que se faz
pra função renal, que também são os
exames de rotina, creatinina e urea, né,
que são os exames mais comuns, são
exames de sangue, e os eletrólitos, é só
potássio, que é para ver o equilíbrio
hidroeletrolítico e o ácido úrico
também, que tem uma correlação com a
cidabólica, informação sistêmica. Agora,
existe também um exame chamado cistatina
C para as pessoas que têm creatinina
aumentada por razão de dieta ou por
estar ingerindo, por exemplo, a
creatina, que aumenta a creatinina de
uma maneira que não se correlaciona
exatamente com perda de função renal.
Então, alguns casos de dúvida, a gente
pede também a cistatina C ou pede o
clearance ou depuração de creatinina.
Então essa já é a resposta dos exames de
função renal. Ureia, creatinina,
cistatina C, em alguns casos depuração
de creatinina ou clearance de
creatinina. Função do fígado, a gente
pede TGO, né, que é o SLT, TGP, tá? Eh,
também outro exame de função renal,
desculpa, eh, o TGO, que é o ah AS, e o
TGP, que é o ALT, né, que são as outras
siglas que corresponde a TJ TGP. O gama
GT é a fosfatase alcalina, né? E é comum
que esses enzimas aumentem em casos de
esteatose hepática não alcoólica,
que é o acúmulo de gordura no fígado. A
gente pede também os perfis de vitaminas
e nutricional, vitamina D, vitamina B12,
ácido fólico, vitamina A, vitamina C.
Apesar do plano de saúde geralmente não
autorizar a vitamina E, a vitamina K. Em
alguns casos a gente pede também esses
exames,
a ferritina, que é um marcador tanto de
depósito de ferro quanto de inflamação.
E valores elevados podem estar indicando
tanto inflamação quanto a doença mais
rara hemocromatose, que é a doença de
acúmulo de ferro. o zinco, que é um
mineral muito importante paraa função
prostática, pra função sexual,
testosterona também pra função imune.
O cobre, né, muito importante, né, pra
questão de anemia também, né, e também
paraa saúde do sistema nervoso central.
Marcadores inflamatórias e autoimunes,
né? fator antinuclear, fator
remumatoide, peço de rotina para todas
as idades. Avaliação com hemograma para
série branca e série vermelha para
identificar tanto a anemia quanto
processos inflamatórios ocultos,
alterações hematológicas primárias, como
algumas doenças de sangue.
E assim, homens entre 40 e 45 anos sem
fatores de risco, a gente faz a
avaliação do perfil metabólico básico,
que eu já comentei, hormonal
simplificado, para aqueles têm risco
familiar ou PSA. E também te pede as
vitaminas, eh, os outros nutrientes,
hemograma, como eu já falei. Agora,
homens com mais idade, 45 a 50 anos, com
fator de risco adicional, aí a gente
pode pedir além do PSA, se tiver
condições de fazer um exame que o plano
não cobre, esse pH aí, né, que é o
índice de saúde prostática. E a gente
pode também pedir, né, o PCA3 ou até
mesmo a ressonância nuclear magnética se
o PSA vi elevado.
E é recomendado até hoje continuar
fazendo o toque retal.
Precisa desbloquear seu iPhone
e para complementar a avaliação do PSA.
Quais seriam os preparos, né? Acho que
foi também a pergunta da função renal.
Eh, realmente é o jejum, né, que eles
pedem jejum de 8 a 10 horas. E pro
exame de PSA se se sugere fazer
abstinência sexual de 48 horas, evitar o
ciclismo ou motocicleta por 2 dias e
aguardar 3 dias após o toque retal para
fazer a coleta de sangue. Se for fazer o
tração transretal, tem que esperar 7
dias.
Bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Diabético acima de 50 anos tem visão
falhando? Vai fazer exame com
oftalmologista? Quais dicas você dá para
encontrar um bom profissional? Para essa
análise, deve dilatar a pupila ou ele
deve analisar
se o açúcar
do sangue está alto? Não entendi essa
pergunta. Ou se ele pode ou ele pode
analisar se é causado pelo açúcar alto
sem dilatar pupila. Não tem que dilatar
pro Pila, já vou falar sobre isso. Quais
aparelhos geralmente eles usam para eu
saber se ele vai usar?
Bem, para você encontrar um
oftalmologista adequado para pessoas
diabéticas,
você deve procurar um especialista em
retina e vítrio, né? um ftalmologista
com subespecialização nessas áreas,
principalmente retina, que é o órgão
mais afetado por essa doença. A
retinopatia diabética é uma doença
retiniana complexa que requer uma
avaliação de um profissional com essa
subespecialidade.
Verificar se o profissional fez
residência médica em oftalmologia
reconhecida pelo MEC e se fez um
fellowship ou especialização em retina.
O consultório deve estar minimamente
equipado, dispor de equipamentos, como é
o caso da tomografia de coerência
óptica, o retinógrafo digital e ter
capacidade para realizar a angiografia.
Então tem que ter uma documentação que
esse profissional fica atualizado,
participo de congressos, né? seria
interessante
e profissionais que têm ética, que
valoriza um controle clínico rigoroso
antes sair indicando procedimentos
invasivos, né? Então, a dilatação
pupilar, ela é absolutamente necessária
para fazer o exame adequado da retina e
para averiguar se existe retinopatia
diabética. E então isso não é uma
negociação, né? É importante que haja a
dilatação, né? Então, exame com
dilatação permite visualização completa
do polo posterior e periferia retiniana,
que é muito importante nessa avaliação.
E se você não dilatar, as lesões
periféricas importantes podem passar
despercebidas.
Tanto a Academia Americana de
Oftalmologia quanto a Sociedade
Brasileira de Oftalmologia recomendam
explicitamente a dilatação para exames
diabéticos. Então esse colírio, né, que
causa amidase, né, dilatação da pupila,
ele vai atuar em aproximadamente 20 a 40
minutos. O efeito vai durar por volta de
4 a 6 horas, tá? Teria alguma coisa
contra a dilatação? Sim, porque ele
provoca uma visão tuva temporária, pode
causar também a fotofobia, que é a luz
incomodar durante algumas horas e você
não pode dirigir, necessita de
acompanhante. Então, seria essas
desvantagens, mas a grande vantagem é
você conseguir visualizar completamente
a rotina toda, detectar precocemente as
lesões periféricas e conseguir utilizar
lentes especiais para poder examinar de
forma detalhada a retina e o disco
óptico.
Então, não é recomendado fazer esse
exame sem dilatação.
Não é recomendado.
A fondoscopia simples, ela vai causar
várias limitações, vai permitir somente
a visualização da área central, que é a
mácula, não vai detectar lesões
periféricas, que eu acabei de mencionar,
onde frequentemente acontece o problema
e pode dar uma falsa sensação de
segurança ao paciente.
Então, quais são os aparelhos que
geralmente são utilizados no exame
oftalmológico da retina, né?
Oftalmoscopia
indireta,
retinografia digital,
o tomógrafo de coerência óptica
e angiografia por OCT, tá? Essa aí é uma
tecnologia mais recente que dispensa uso
de contraste endovenoso e visualiza a
microvasculatura retiniana em 3
segundos.
Existe também o tonômetro,
que é importante para saber se a pessoa
tem glaucoma relacionado à doença da
retina.
E existe também um exame chamado
angfluroenografia,
que é mais invasivo, né? Porque requer
injeção de contraste fluoriceína,
mas permite uma visualização dinâmica da
circulação retiniana.
Porém, é um exame que hoje está sendo
gradualmente substituído pela tomografia
de coerência óptica e também pela
angiografia por OCT.
Lembrando que o mais importante para o
diabético é sempre controlar a glicemia,
porque cada redução de 1% da hemoglobina
glicada reduz em 35% o risco de
progressão da retinopatia. Então esse é
o mais importante ainda do que fazer
qualquer tipo de avaliação específica da
retina.
Bem, tem algumas observações da Dra. Ana
Paula aqui. Obrigado pela observação
carinhosa.
Explica sobre obesidade importante nos
homens cada vez mais cedo e uma sarcopnê
mesmo em jovens.
É, tem muitos homens hoje com baixa
testosterona, seja por intoxicação
ambiental, por cheno estrógeno, mas
também por maus hábitos de vida, né?
Ingerir açúcar demais e não fazer
atividade física, especialmente esse de
força.
É, tem bastante homens com
hipotiroidismo. Você tem razão.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Há um tempo atrás, vi resultado de uma
pesquisa que dizia que 67% das
inflamações nos seres humanos vinham do
açúcar. Essa é uma verdade para todos.
Bem, eu não encontrei na literatura esse
número aí que você colocou, 67% das
inflamações serem pelo açúcar, né?
Porém, a gente sabe que o açúcar, sim, é
um fator muito importante para a
inflamação. A relação entre o consumo de
açúcar e processo inflamatório já tá
extensamente documentada,
é multifatorial, é complexa, né? Envolve
a glicação, que é a caramelização das
proteínas do organismo. Isso forma
produtos de glicação avançada, né, na
sigla inglês AGE. Isso desencadeia
cascatas inflamatórias que ativam
receptores específicos e produz espécies
reativas de oxigênio. E também acontece
um problema em termos de metabolismo no
fígado, metabolismo hepático, né? A
frutose em excesso é metabolizada
exclusivamente nesse órgão, promove a
formação de gordura, lipogênese e a
produção então de ácidos grassos que vão
ser incorporados no tecido gorduroso e
também que podem promover processos
inflamatórios através de metabólitos
lipotóxicos,
tá? Então, tem vários mecanismos, já
falamos da glicação, já falamos da
transformação da frutose em gordura no
fígado. Tem também a disbiose
intestinal, que é o consumo excessivo de
açúcar, altera a flora, né, o microbiota
e vai reduzir as bactérias benéficas,
como é o caso da prevotela, e aumenta a
permabilidade intestinal.
Isso facilita a translocação de
lipopolissacaridos,
que são constituintes da parede
bacteriana. Isso vai ativar receptores
inflamatórios, como é o caso do TLR4 e a
via NFK beta. Existe também a questão da
resistência insulínica, né? Os picos
glicêmicos repetidos levam à
hiperinsulinemia, que por si só é
inflamatório, né? Então essa
hiperinsulinemia compensatória cria um
estado pró-inflamatório sistêmicos.
Então existe várias evidências
disponíveis. Um estudo mostrou que
consumir 40 g de açúcar adicionado, que
equivale a uma lata de refrigerante por
dia, durante três semanas já aumentou de
maneira significativa várias marcadoras
inflamatórias, como é o caso da proteína
serrativa. A Organização Mundial de
Saúde recomenda limitar o consumo de
açúcar a menos de 10% das calorias
diárias totais. Eu recomendo o mínimo
possível de açúcar.
Idealmente menos de 5%
baseando-se em evidência sobre os
efeitos ruins do açúcar. E tem aí
pesquisas que identificaram 45
consequências negativas
associadas ao consumo excessivo de
açúcar, incluindo o próprio diabetes,
que é óbvio, né? Mas também doenças
menos óbvias, como gota, obesidade,
hipertensão, doenças cardiovasculares e
câncer.
Então, nós sabemos que sim, o açúcar é
um dos principais fatores que levam à
inflamação sistêmica de baixo grau,
porém ela é multifatorial, não é só o
açúcar, contribui também para isso,
estresse crônico, uso de gorduras
artificiais, como é o caso da gordura
transgenada,
o excesso de ácidos grácios em geral que
podem vir do fígado pelo metabolismo do
da frutose, como eu já falei, o
sedentarismo, a falta de atividade
física, obesidade de modo geral, excesso
de calorias, né? Estresse crônico,
tabagismo, consumo excessivo de álcool,
exposição a poluentes ambientais, como
já falei, até dos xenoestrógenos.
Então, é muito importante tá ligado
nisso tudo e não só eh lembrar do
açúcar, né?
Próxima pergunta. Anteriormente, uma
pessoa perguntou se o problema dele
poderia ser Alzheimer.
Ah, sim. É uma pergunta que tá vindo
toda semana de um jovem aí que tem um
comportamento estranho. Já me
perguntaram umas três, quatro vezes se é
Alzheimer, se é TDAH, se é autismo.
Gente, eu não vou conseguir fazer esse
diagnóstico aqui para vocês, tá? Eu já
especulei sobre vários diagnósticos
e, enfim, tô, a pergunta tá voltando
toda semana, né? Mas vamos lá. Você
disse que pela idade aquela pessoa era
muito jovem para Teos Hames. Sim,
inclusive na mesma semana eu soltei um
vídeo falando o caso raríssimo de um
jovem com Alzheimer,
né? A notícia do jovem de 19 anos, né?
Que eu até falei nas minhas redes
sociais. Eu lhe pergunto, um jovem de 28
anos com muito esquecimento, esquece em
que local deixou a moto com frequência?
Por exemplo, já esqueceu os alimentos no
caixa do supermercado,
rei sozinha, fala sozinho como forma de
aliviar ansiedade, mas tem consciência e
quando uma pessoa desconhecida aparece,
ele para de fazer os gestos
involuntários com as mãos.
E um colega dele há uns 7 anos falou que
ele parecia avó que ficava esquecendo as
coisas. Ele apenas comparou e isso
serviu de alerta para esse homem de 28
anos. Tem problemas de sociabilização.
A sua visão pode ser Alzheimer. Já
comentei sobre isso, mas vamos lá. Vamos
de novo. Autismo, esquizofrenia, leve ou
uma mescla. Tá
bem. Eh, esse caso que eu falei do jovem
chinês de 19 anos que teve o diagnóstico
é raríssimo, tá? A gente não pode tomar
isso como uma
um exemplo, né, para fazer outros
diagnósticos.
as possibilidades, tá, para esse rapaz,
né, aos ram de início precoce, né, o que
seria os prós, né, muito raro, mas vamos
falar quais seriam os pró para esse
diagnóstico. seria a questão da pesa de
memória que aparentemente ele tem, né? O
início gradual dos sintomas,
aparentemente a 7 anos, um
comprometimento funcional das atividades
diárias,
mas como eu falei, é muito, muito raro,
tá?
Porém, houve um aumento de 200% nos
diagnósticos de Alam entre 30 e 64 anos
entre 2013 e 2017 nos Estados Unidos.
Quais são os contras? para esse
diagnóstico de Alzheimer, extremamente
raro nessa idade, não tem outros
sintomas cognitivos típicos que é
desorientação temporal, a afasia e a
praxia.
Se bem que depois ela soltou uma outra
informação falando que sim, que poderia
ter a fazia, né? Já vou voltar nesse
assunto. Consciência preservada sobre os
comportamentos. A pessoa tem
consciência,
ausência de deteriorização progressiva
mais grave, né? nos últimos anos
e falar sozinho como estratégia de
alívio não é típico do Alzheimer, tá? Eu
acho que existe uma possibilidade bem
razoável de ser um teia, né? Um
transtorno do espectro autista. Os pró
para esse diagnóstico
é o problema de sociabilização que foi
mencionado, é os comportamentos
repetitivos também próprio do Alzheimer,
desculpa, do do do TEA, né, do
transtorno de espectro autista, que são
gestos involuntários com as mãos. Falar
sozinho como autorregulação também é
típico de TEA. Consciência e modificação
do comportamento na presença de
estranhos, que é o meskim, também pode
ser típico do autismo. Possível
trajetória desde a infância não
diagnosticado.
Tem muitos adultos agora sendo
diagnosticados tardiamente com té,
especialmente segal de suporte um contra
o tea, nesse caso desse rapaz,
esquecimento não é característico de
terra, né? você tem esquecimento, não
enquadraria o início dos sintomas mais
evidentes na idade adulta, jovem,
aparentemente, é isso que a pessoa tá me
relatando aqui, falta de informações
sobre padrões restritos de interesse,
não é o caso, né? Não parece que tem
padrões restritos que é como no tea, né?
Ausência de relatos sobre dificuldades
sensoriais, que também é como nuteia,
OK? E o comportamento não parece seguir
um padrão rígido.
Vamos falar um pouquinho de
esquizofrenia. Pró para esse
diagnóstico.
Idade típica de início, final da
adolescência, início dos 20 anos. Falar
e rir sozinho pode ser alucinações
auditivas. Problema de sociabilização,
isolamento também pode acontecer na
esquizofrenia.
Comportamentos motores anormais, gestos
involuntários é possível. e consciência
parcial mantida em quadros iniciais.
Agora, o que que é contra aí
esquizofrenia nesse caso? Ausência e
sintomas positivos claros, que é o
delírio estruturado, alucinações
evidentes. A pessoa mantém consciência e
controle comportamental, que não é comum
no caso da esquizofrenia, falta de
desorganização do pensamento da fala,
ausência de deterioração,
deteriorização funcional mais grave e
esquecimento também não é sintoma
primário de esquizofrenia, tá? Então,
poderia ser uma mistura de tea com TDH
esse paciente. Poderia. Poderia ser um
tea com uma psicose leve associado.
Poderia. Poderia ser um transtorno
neurocognitivo.
Sim,
poderia.
Agora, a pessoa depois eh começou, teve
uma outra pergunta que é eh adicionando
elementos a esse caso, né?
Então, a pessoa aparentemente tem
parafasi, que é trocas de palavras com
autocorreção imediata, né? Então isso
pode levantar outras hipóteses
diagnósticas.
Então, a presença dessas trocas de
palavras, que a gente chama de parafasia
com autocorreção imediata,
é um sintoma neurológico que pode
indicar problemas no circuito de
linguagem. Então, hipóteses revisadas,
poderia ser uma afasia progressiva
primária, é uma doença rara, né? Quais
são os prós para isso?
é a autocorreção, como foi falado, o
início aos 21 anos de idade,
aparentemente foi nessa idade que
começou a progressão lenta ao longo de 7
anos, a consciência preservada dos
déficits, a anomia compensada, né, que é
você esquecer o nome das coisas,
o problema de sociabilização secundária,
né? Então é possível ser isso. Agora,
tem que fazer uma avaliação
neuropsiquiátrica, né? Certo? Existe
também uma possibilidade de ser uma
demência frontemporal com variante
comportamental. Raro também, muito raro,
mas é uma possibilidade.
OK? Então,
investigação, tem que fazer uma
avaliação neuropsicológica, uma
avaliação foneioológica,
tem que fazer exames de neuroimagem, né?
uma ressonância nuclear magnética
cerebral, um pet CT scan do cérebro para
ver algum problema de hipometabolismo do
da glicose, alguma parte do cérebro,
talvez um pet amiloide, se a hipótese aí
de Alzheimer for mais acentuada,
biomarcadores, né, no colher o líquor,
né, e pesquisar proteína tal, pesquisar
betamide,
então neurofilamento de cadeia leve,
fazer aí painel genético para demências
hereditárias.
Então isso aí tem que fazer uma
avaliação bem completa, tá? Tem um gên
da PP, né, que é o gene da demência
frontemporal
também, o gene do próprio Alzheimer,
tá?
Vamos pra próxima pergunta aqui.
Ana Paula tá até falando aqui que eu
falei demais, né? Você tem razão, né?
Tem que passar por uma avaliação
neuropsiquiátrica.
Cínimo alcoólica fetal pode dar esses
sintomas. Boa lembrança, Dra. Ana Paula
aqui.
H. Eu vou falar, tem uma pergunta sobre
esse melotime aqui que eu vou falar
daqui a pouco, tá?
Gluten também influi o quê, Alice?
Não sei do que que você tá falando.
Desculpa, porque eu falei de um monte de
coisa já aqui
para mim. É, viu, Eliseu? Essa história
do bebê reborne tá parecendo para mim
doença mental. Sim.
Olha o recado da Dra. Ana Paula aqui.
Bem, vamos pro próxima pergunta. Qual
médico psiquiatra você recomenda para
diagnóstico e tratamento no Brasil?
Bem, eu geralmente recomendo o Dr.
Joarez Calegara, só que ele tá ficando
bem idoso. Eu não sei se ele vai
continuar atendendo por muito mais
tempo. Ele é originalmente de Porto
Alegre. Parece que ele continua
atendendo em Porto Alegre, mas ele se
mudou para Brasília.
Ele é um cara genial, né? Ele mistura
psiquiatria com o ortomolecular. Ele é
um dos precursores no Brasil da
ortomolecular. Ele foi colega Dr. Hion
Povo que foi precursor no Brasil da
molecular.
Então ele é, minha primeira recomendação
é o Dr. Juarez Calegaro, tá?
Ã, tem o Dr. Frederico Porto, que é de
Belo Horizonte, é o filho do lá Ribeiro,
né? Então é nutrólogo e psiquiatra,
autor de livros.
Então ele tem o site dele,
fredericopporto.com.br.
Tem o Dr. Sérgio Clepax,
que eu já vi algumas vezes, não conheço
ele muito bem, mas já encontrei ele em
eventos. Ele é um psiquiatra já também
das antigas, desde 1983,
tem mestrada, diretor da clínica Total
Balance,
também autor de livros. Esse aqui atende
São Paulo, na rua Mato Grosso, ali na
região do Genópolis.
Tem um site dele que é o
totalbalance.com.br.
Tem o Dr. Eduardo Adnê que é do Rio de
Janeiro. Esse não conheço de
pessoalmente,
que você vai conseguir falar com ele
através do site telemedicina.com
ou dradine.com.
Ad escreve com D mudo e T mudo no final.
Adnê, tá?
Então, esses seria esses profissionais
que eu recomendaria. Você também pode
consultar no site
abmfuncionalintegrativa.com.br,
abfuncionalintegrativa.com.br.
Tá?
Próxima pergunta. Existem problemas de
visão não necessariamente relacionados à
diabetes que se não for tratado, pode
levar a cegueira? Se uma pessoa tem
problema de visão e vai na ótica e lá
não tem oftalmologista, eles fazem só
exame de letras e dão grau do óculos
baseado nesse exame, isso pode mascarar
algo mais grave? Sim, não recomendo
fazer isso.
Bem, os principais problemas oculares é
o glaucoma, que é aumento da pressão
intraocular. Eu tenho uma tia, minha
querida, que tem um glaucoma severo. Ela
é quase cega, coitada, por conta disso.
Então é uma das principais causas de
cegueira irreversível.
É caracterizado pelo aumento da pressão
dentro do olho intraocular. Isso vai
danificando o nervo óptico.
Então é importante tá sendo sempre vendo
a pressão intraocular uma vez por ano,
porque é uma doença que desenvolve de
maneira muito lenta e progressiva,
excelenciosa. E a pessoa só percebe
perda de visão já tarde demais. Então,
por isso que tem que fazer uma
prevenção.
Então, quando geralmente o paciente já
percebe alterações visuais, os danos já
são irreversíveis e significativos.
Então, estima-se que 1 milhão de pessoas
no Brasil tm a glaucoma.
A segunda doença mais comum é a
degeneração macular,
que é a principal causa de seguir em
idosos a partir dos 60 anos de idade.
Ela tem duas formas, a forma seca e a
forma úmida. A forma seca é de
progressão lenta e a úmida que é mais
rara é progressão rápida. e o paciente
vai perdendo o campo central da visão,
mantendo apenas a visão periférica.
Então isso aqui também é uma doença
grave que tem que ser identificada e
tratada rapidamente.
E temos a catarata, que todo mundo
conhece, mas que é a causa mais comum de
cegueira reversível.
Representa mesmo assim metade dos casos
de cegueira mundial, né? Porque os
países aí menos envolvidos não tm essa
assistência.
eh tranquila de ficar trocando, né, o
cristalino, fazendo cirurgia, né? Então
é a opacificação progressiva da lente do
olho cristalina e vai causando visão
embaçada, sensibilidade à luz, alteração
na percepção de cores e se não houver
tratamento cirúrgico, evolui até a perda
total da visão. Tem também menos comum,
mas também que vocês devem ter ouvido
falar já o descolamento de retina, que é
uma emergência oftalmológica e requer
tratamento imediato. Isso acontece
porque a retina se separa da parede
posterior do olho. Isso pode causar uma
perda visual rápida e irreversível se
não for tratado de forma urgente. E tem
outras doenças mais raras ainda que é o
seratocone, que são doenças da córnea,
úlceras da córnea e outras alterações
que podem comprometer de forma severa a
visão.
mais raro ainda tem as inflamações da
uvia, né, as uveitses ou inflamações
intraoculares.
Então são processos inflamatórios que
podem afetar diferentes partes ou
estruturas do olho, levando a
complicações graves como glaucoma
secundário e danos permanente à visão.
Esse exame que você comentou de só fazer
a tabela de letras nas óticas tem sim um
risco significativo, porque você não tá
avaliando a pressão intraocular, você
não tá avaliando a retina, isso pode
simcarar condições mais graves.
Então, principalmente porque você não tá
medindo a pressão intraocular e nem um
fundo de olho.
e também não tá fazendo um exame de
lâmpada de fenda que avalia o segmento
anterior do olho e permite identificar
alterações de córnea, de cristalino, de
íris e outras estruturas.
Além disso, essa pessoa pode não ter
tido o cuidado de passarem o médico de
modo geral e pode não ter sido
identificado outros problemas
sistêmicos, né, do corpo inteiro, como
pressão alta, diabetes, doença
autoimune, que podem interferir no olho,
né? Então esse é outro problema de você
não passar em médico antes de tentar
pegar uma receita aí de óculos.
Bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Na live passada perguntei se a película
que bloqueia a luz solar, desculpa, a
luz azul do celular funciona e você
respondeu que teria que pesquisar.
Conseguiu pesquisar? Sim. Fiz uma
pesquisa e a informação que obtive é que
essas películas bloqueadoras de luz azul
no celular bloqueiam entre 30 a 60% da
luz azul no comprimento de onda de 450
nanôm.
Essa eficácia ela vai variar conforme o
dispositivo e a marca da película, mas
você vê que o bloqueio não é maior do
que 60%.
A vantagem da película é que preservaria
as cores normais da tela. diferente você
colocar aquele aplicativo de modo
noturno, só que o modo noturno reduz
muito mais, reduz entre 81 a 86% a luz
azul,
tá? Então é muito mais eficiente o
aplicativo do que a película.
Bem, eu não recomendaria as películas,
não recomendaria usar o app, tá?
Se você coloca o approca
das das cores e reduz a luminosidade da
tela, é muito mais eficiente que usar a
película.
E além disso, é importante frisar que
tem que reduzir o tempo de tela antes de
dormir. É recomendado fazer a regra 20
20, que a cada 20 minutos você olhar
algo a 6 m de distância por 20 segundos
para poder ficar treinando a visão.
Então essa é a minha posição sobre essa
questão dessa película aí. Não acho
grande vantagem não.
Não acho que vale a pena comprar não.
Na live passada você disse que
ressonância de coluna não dá câncer. Não
falei bem isso, tá?
Quer dizer, eu falei que exames que
provocam câncer é de radiação ionizante.
A ressonância não usa radiação
ionizante, né? E logo em seguida, se eu
entendi direito, você quis dizer que
tomografia ou raio X pode dar câncer.
Depende da exposição. Quantos raios X da
coluna eu posso fazer por ano para não
correr risco de pegar câncer?
Bem, quais são as doses típicas de
radiação exames de coluna, né? Raio X.
01 a 1,5
msv, que é a unidade aí de medida de
radiação.
O rax de coluna cervical são 0,2 msv, o
dorsal torácica 0,7 a1, lombar de 1 a
1,5 e colã total para escoliose 1,5 a 3.
Então você poderia fazer em torno de 20
a 30 exames desse por ano, tá?
e no máximo para não ter uma carga
excessiva de radiação. Já a tomografia
computadorizada de coluna é muito mais,
tá, do que um rax de coluna. Enquanto
que o rax de coluna é 01 a 1,5, a
tomografia computadorizada vai de 5 a 10
msv. Então é muitas vezes 30 a 50 vezes
mais. Então tomografia você poderia tá
fazendo no máximo três por ano, tá?
Evidências dizem que você poderia se
expor a radiação ionizante, que é do
raio X da tomografia,
ah, até 50 a 100 msv por ano, tá?
Ou 10 a 50 msv de uma vez só.
Então é isso que eu falei, você poderia
fazer em torno, no máximo, de 30 rax por
ano e no máximo uns três tomografia. Se
puder fazer só uma melhor ainda por ano,
tá?
Perguntei sobre transplante capilar na
live passada e você explicou sobre os
sintomas da dutasterida, síndrome
pósdutasterida, a gente chama mais de
síndrome pósfinasterida, tá? Apesar da
droga tasterida ser mais forte, é a
síndrome que dá depressão, queda de
libido, disfunção erétil. Esses sintomas
ocorrem apenas nos primeiros dias após o
transplante ou é para sempre?
Bem, é complicado responder isso, tá?
Então, paraa maioria dos pacientes que
tem efeito colateral com a finasterida
ou com a tutasterida,
os sintomas vão desaparecer após algumas
semanas da suspensão do medicamento. É o
que acontece com mais frequência.
Porém, a literatura já caracterizou
muitas pessoas com sín pósfinasterida.
E nesses casos,
por
definição, a persistência dos sintomas
ocorre pelo menos 3 meses após a
descontinuação dos medicamentos.
Então, existe casos moderados
que demoram de três a 6 meses após a
interrupção da medicação para retorno ao
equilíbrio,
casos persistentes que podem durar anos
e casos que aparentemente não houve
melhora mesmo anos depois da suspensão
de duração então indefinida.
Então existe uma imprevisibilidade. A
literatura médica indica que pode
ocorrer mesmo com o uso de curta
duração, dias ou semanas e doses baixas
da finasterida, da dutasterida, e a
gravidade e duração dos sintomas parecem
ser independentes da dose utilizada ou
do tempo de tratamento. Então é muito
imprevisível, tá? Os mecanismos
fisiopatológicos ainda não estão
totalmente
elucidad. a evidência de alterações
estruturais pinianas, mudança na
densidade dos receptores androgênicos e
possíveis mecanismos epigenéticos.
Então, alguns estudos sugerem alterações
histológicas potencialmente permanentes,
incluindo diminuição do músculo liso,
né, no caso do corpo cavernoso e aumento
do colágeno dentro do pênis.
Então, não há como saber, tá? pode durar
dias, semanas, anos ou até mesmo nunca
melhorar, tá? Então, se for utilizar,
utiliza só na forma intra dérmica, né?
Não, no couro cabeludo. Eu não recomendo
usar via oral, OK? Mesmo assim, né?
Teria um risco muito pequeno, mas teria
da forma intradérmica
dar problema.
Tem perguntas aqui ao vivo.
O Brasil é um dos países com mais
doentes mentais do mundo. Não tenho essa
informação, Antônio. Eu sei que o Brasil
é um dos países que tem mais ansiedade e
depressão. Agora, doenças mentais de
modo geral não tem essa informação.
Próxima semana teremos live, não sei
ainda, né? Porque eu vou tirar umas
miniférias aí.
E a gente vai decidir ainda se
terça-feira que vem vai ter live ou não.
Eu acho que o risco é muito pequeno,
Antônio Renato, tá? Para você não fazer
dilatação
da pupila e correr risco de não ter um
bom diagnóstico, tá?
Eu prefiro aplicativo do que essas
películas, pelo que eu vi, né, nas
pesquisas.
Teremos uma aula de metabolômica da
Fagron às 20 horas.
Nem tava lembrando disso, Ana Paula. Nem
tava.
Bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta aqui.
No inverno, as pessoas sofrem mais
choque térmico e o choque térmico leva a
queda de imunidade, apesar de que muita
gente fez faz choque térmico
propositalmente para aumentar a
longevidade, mas é um contexto
diferente.
Como é que eu sei que determinado choque
térmico está aumentando a longevidade ou
diminuindo a imunidade? Tá uma boa
pergunta.
A diferença entre o choque térmico
benéfico, que é a Ormese, e o choque
térmico prejudicial reside em alguns
detalhes que eu vou comentar aqui.
Então, a ormese térmica, ela é
caracterizada por exposições
controladas, graduais e de intensidade
moderada que vão permitir a adaptação
celular progressiva. Então, os
parâmetros que indicam essa resposta
hormética inclui intensidade e duração
controladas. Então, a literatura
científica demonstra que temperaturas
entre 38 e 48ºC,
né, seria uma sauna, né, por períodos de
15 a 30 minutos para calor ou reduções
de temperatura corporal abaixo de 37ºC,
sem atingir hipotermia, tendem a induzir
a ormese,
então, exposições mais intensas ou
prolongadas
ultrapassariam então o limear
benéfico.
Então, seria necessário um tempo de
recuperação adequado, intervalos maiores
entre exposições que permitiriam que os
mecanismos adaptativos se consolidassem.
Então, exposições muito frequentes ou
sem tempo de recuperação poderiam
impedir a resposta ormética.
Então, a Ormese induz aumento controlado
e sustentado de proteínas de choque
térmico, né, as chamadas chaperonas ou
HSPs,
especialmente HSP70
e a 90, que permanecem elevadas por 24 a
48 horas após o estímulo. E essas
proteínas atuariam como chaperonas
moleculares, protegendo outras proteínas
contra desnaturação e agregação.
da Ormese tem esses benefícios aí de
aumentar as chaperonas, né, as HSPs e
também atua ativando fatores de
transcrição, que é um caso do HSF1, do
Fox 3, das cirtuínas e do NF NRF2,
que são associados a processos
antioxidantes, antiinflamatórios e de
reparo celular, tá? Então, quanto é que
seria negativo o choque térmico, né?
Quais são as características do choque
térmico prejudicial? Transições súbitas
entre temperaturas muito diferentes, né?
Diferenças superiores a 15 a 20º que não
permitiriam adaptação fisiológica
adequada. Isso aqui também é polêmico,
né? Porque se você tá numa sauna e vai
para uma banheira gelada, como muita
gente faz, como é o caso do Dr. Sinclair
faz, né? Isso já estaria dentro dessa
característica de ser e maléfico, né?
Então é um pouco contraditório isso
aqui.
E os sintomas então de um choque térmico
maléfico seriam sintomas como câbras,
alterações de pressão arterial, parálise
temporária de cílios respiratórios,
aumentando a suscetibilidade a
infecções. em casos extremos, arritmias
cardíacas ou eventos cérebrovasculares.
Então, na prática, se você está
experimentando
eh ormese ou choque térmico, como é que
você vai extinguir? Então observe a
sensação durante e após a exposição,
porque na ormésia você tem um
desconforto tolerável, seguido uma
sensação de bem-estar e vitalidade.
Então, quando você faz o choque térmico,
você tem essa sensação desconforto
seguido de bem-estar, né? e o choque
prejudicial causa um mal-estar
persistente.
Em termos cardiovasculares,
na Ormese há um aumento controlado de
frequência cardíaca com recuperação
rápida e no choque prejudicial pode
ocorrer arritmias ou recuperação
prolongada.
e também na mese a melhora da
resistência a infecções nos dias
seguintes e no choque prejudicial
aumenta a susceptibilidade a doenças
respiratórias.
A hormese melhoraria a clareza mental e
a resistência física nos dias
subsequentes e quanto que o choque
prejudicial causaria fadiga persistente.
Então essa janela terapêutica é bem
controversa e estreita.
Então é muito individual isso daí, tá?
não tem uma resposta muito firme qual
que é a transição aí da Ormese para o
choque térmico maléfico.
Tem mais uma pergunta aqui. Enviei um
WhatsApp para uma farmácia de
manipulação com a seguinte mensagem:
suplemento melotime slow release 120
cápsulas, 3 mg cada cápsula. Qual que é
o orçamento? O farmacêutico me respondeu
com orçamento. Seguinte eu perguntei:
"Sabe me dizer se é 50% de liberação
rápida e 50 de liberação lenta?" Ele
respondeu: "Melotime é uma marca
patenteada da melatonina de liberação
lenta do fornecedor Galdic.
Essa é somente liberação prolongada. Se
você quiser, podemos manipular a
melatonina duo, que possui uma liberação
rápida e uma lenta. Minha pergunta é:
como devo chamar o produto para que o
farmacêutico entenda? É o melo,
aliás, é a melatonina do mesmo, tá? Na
verdade,
quando eu falei que o melotime era
duplo, porque foi isso que me foi dito
pela farmacêutica, mas depois eu fui ver
e realmente você tem razão. O melotime
não é metade liberação rápida e metade
lenta, é todo liberação lenta, tá? Então
você pode pedir então como farmácia te
orientou a melatonina duo, tá?
é essa melatonina que tem 50% de
liberação rápida e 50% de liberação
lenta.
Então você pode pedir para o
farmacêutico a melatonina duo 3 mg.
Existe também a melatonina bifásica
e a melatonina time release bifásica.
Então isso foi uma um equívoco da minha
parte que fui pela orientação da
farmacêutica e não fui checar a
informação de uma maneira mais segura.
Próxima pergunta. Aliás, não tem próxima
pergunta. Deixa eu ver os comentários ao
vivo. Eu tinha uns artigos aqui para
falar para vocês, mas tá atingindo uma
hora de live aqui. Eu acho melhor deixar
para semana que vem.
Então, Alice, quando você disse aqui
glúten também influi. Tava falando do
que aqui para poder te responder?
Se você tá falando dessa pergunta aqui,
eu já respondi, Eliseu. Acabei de
responder.
Mas se for de liberação lenta, não dá
para ser sublingual, não faz sentido,
tá? Teria que ser vi oral.
Não tem como ser liberação lenta
sublingual, tem que ser oral.
Isso aqui eu não posso responder para
você. Como é que faz para convencer
alguém de alguma coisa? Conversa com
eles, né?
Bem, pessoal, parece que não tem mais
perguntas, né?
Desejo vocês uma excelente semana e nós
nos vemos na semana que vem. Um abraço
para vocês.